hydrogen the most plentiful element in
the universe
on earth we find it mostly bonded to
oxygen in the form of water or in other
gases known as hydrocarbons hydrogen gas
h2 burns hot and clean making it an
attractive tool in the race to net zero
but isolating hydrogen from other
elements is no easy task
today the cheapest way to do this is via
chemical processes that break up natural
gas
this releases a lot of carbon dioxide
another method is to use electricity to
split water molecules in a process
called electrolysis although there is no
carbon byproduct a lot of electricity is
needed
and if this power comes from burning
coal or gas it negates the zero
emissions goals of using hydrogen to
begin with hydrogen produced in this way
powered by fossil fuels is called gray
hydrogen
if carbon capture and storage is used
together with fossil fuels then it
becomes blue hydrogen if nuclear power
is used it's called pink
and finally green hydrogen is what is
produced via electrolysis and powered
from renewable sources this method is
considered emissions-free it's predicted
that by the early 2030s h2 made for
renewables will be cheaper than that
made from fossil fuels but that hinges
on the cost of electrolysis declining
which will be achieved through larger
projects and an expansion of
manufacturing to be clear vast amounts
of h2 are already used today global
production in 2018 totaled 117 million
metric tons this hydrogen is mostly used
for its chemical properties not as a
source of energy and very little of it
is clean some sectors like steel could
start using hydrogen for these chemical
properties replacing coal industries
like cement and glass may also use
hydrogen as a source of heat
another advantage is its energy storage
potential it can be stored over long
periods of time and used when more power
needs to be added to the grid it also
could hold an advantage over batteries
in heavy transport and shipping
the promise of hydrogen for energy has
been around since at least 1874 when
jules verne wrote about it in his book
the mysterious island but the future of
hydrogen will depend on policy countries
with net zero targets carbon pricing and
hydrogen strategies with investment
mechanisms are likely to see the highest
h2 demand
you